the arrest was orchestrated by her by
her saying that I was suddenly aware of
the investigation and planning on
destroying evidence so Financial control
coercive control use and domestic groups
yeah even though you have all the
evidence and the messages that prove
otherwise so
um she claimed that when we were
together there was an Issa so the first
time apparently we slept together by
Foster into having sex but then we had a
10-year relationship after that and
there was she and her sister concocted a
story that I would try to have with her
in my sleep and and there was no
evidence no one no messages like you
know with 10 years of history between
all in all WhatsApp between all no one
could ever find a message yeah and then
uh probably the worst and most
horrific one was he accused me of her
and that's how our second child came
about and the money that I have paid for
my Barrister and solicitor about 10
grand at this point
is gone there is no way for me to
recover that she didn't turn up to a
hearing and I paid 10 grand for it in
the last two court hearings I had to go
unrepresented because I ran out of money
so actually if I'd paid for the last two
last two court hearings it would have
been about another four or five thousand
pounds so it was on my mind
like
genuinely like it got dark and she
brazenly said yes I did hit him because
he was annoying
and the judge went oh okay I moved on
[Music]
so uh what what was your name again
James James okay I'm Pearl nice to meet
you so I want to hear first about how
did you meet your ex we weirdly met we
met a house party and it was a friend of
a friend and we kind of just bonded over
time and you know did the standard chat
over Facebook and then things progressed
um both of us were having sort of a bad
time mental health-wise at the at the
time
um
just kind of built from there okay so
you guys are like both depressed and
then you Blended over that maybe yeah
um she had a lot of mental health
problems sort of building up um I sort
of was having a blip
um so I had like about a year of bad
depression
um anxiety and during that time that's
kind of when we met I'm just wondering
if there was like were there red flags
about her early on like in hindsight I
mean I'm guessing mental health that's
probably a bit yeah I mean it's it's one
of those ones like I've always been very
open about my own mental health and my
my mental health struggles and she was
kind of open about hers and you know I I
didn't see any red flags at the time it
wasn't until after we split up you sort
of go back through the relationship and
go oh yeah that was a problem that was a
problem but I always made excuses for
her saying her mental health was the
reason behind this and I get in a lot of
trouble even now by you know my my
current partner and my my dad my even
now I'll say oh but was that her mental
health or was that her just being
vicious and even now I'm still sort of
you know questioning which one it falls
on yeah because my question is like
there's guys that watch this and it's
just like what red flags were there
early on if any to you that you would
say to like watch out for like just
don't accept any like anything that
would be considered abuse the other way
just flip it in your own mind and but so
she was she was abused yeah
um it's you know because he would hit me
regularly in front of the children oh
wow um I always made an excuse for it
you know it's mental health um she would
be quite emotionally manipulative
um she's like
um I mean there was a lot of
related stuff as well
um if I turned her down for sex she
would make me feel guilty about it
um and would often message me things
like it really helps me sleep and if I
sleep better I don't self-harm wow so
she would say if you didn't sleep with
her that essentially you were you were
making her like yourself or something
yeah it would it would lead that way and
that's what she would imply she would
never out and out say it but like the
messages were sort of very like oh it
really helps me sleep and when I don't
sleep I like I'm self-harm because I get
stressed out and you know everything
hurts more and I feel more depressed and
it's like okay so almost the expectation
but if I ever turned her down
um it was always sort of
along the lines of you're not doing
enough for me did you ever hit her back
nope never mind you never hit her back
I'm a big guy I'm six foot one if I hit
back no one would like that that'd be
the end for me um I'm not a violent
person anyway I don't lash out like you
know I'm quite a big guy like I don't
hit back I very push but never pushed
her like make that clear never like like
I just kind of took it and just sort of
took away himself out the situation
because there is no coming back from
that you swing that way even once it's
game over so essentially you met this
girl at a house party
um and she was pretty open about the
fact that she had mental health issues
how long was it before she started
abusing you so we moved nearer my mum
for my for my support that was sort of
work related stuff I was trying to get
myself back into work back into
employment and then after we moved back
towards her parents things started
becoming more strained and that's when
she started being like more vicious more
when she was with her family
um she cut me off my friends I wasn't
allowed to go out really and speak to
people she cut you out how did she do
that
um anytime I wanted to go out there was
always the guilt of all you're
abandoning me you're abandoning I see by
the end of it the only friends I really
had were actually her
sisters like partners and I would only
see them occasionally at like events and
stuff I wouldn't really chat to my
friends or an online game and chat with
my friends then but I'd always feel
guilty about that and always be
constantly being told to come off stop
talking to your friends friends that
I've been friends with for years like it
was the only way I was keeping in
contact with them and then gradually
that got pulled down and right before we
split up so in sort of the March maybe
March time I made some new friends sort
of from my work related issue
and I work related stuff and then sort
of made friends with that and then the
relationships started going more and
more downhill on things that are ramping
up and then you know that's when hitting
became more regular I was being screamed
at so how I'm just trying to understand
like the timeline because you guys were
together 10 years when did you have kids
um very early on a few kids right away
yeah it wasn't intentional it was kind
of a accidental thing for my son say
Axton it was you know it wasn't planned
um so we uh yeah so she fell pregnant
pretty early on uh like a year in yeah
about about probably not even quite a
year but oh wow so less than a year you
guys were together you started having
kids yeah and then at what point did she
start
um hitting you like how many years in
um after our second one was born so
about four years later so there's a four
year gap between us wow so there so the
first four years there was no and then
it just it was just like a lot of
yelling screaming from you know fights
and whatever it was quite you know
chilled but I was at home a lot of that
time
um I started employment just before
really our second one was sort of had
maybe two years in to employment
um and then we had
a second child and then things start
becoming more strained I was doing a lot
of heavy lifting sort of around the
house looking after the kids but you
know apparently not good enough so I was
working full time coming back and like
you know doing most of the housework as
well she was unemployed at home all the
time kids were at nursery school and I
was still being told you're not doing
enough you need to do more you need to
drive me here drive me there drop this
off you know pay for everything and
while she was kind of not really doing a
lot doing a great deal and then things
started like escalating gradually
um and you know became more physical
more screamy yeah I found out recently
she'd been filtering money off from our
accounts to her parents the entire time
oh wow um so there was a whole account
that I didn't know about that her
parents can that I did know about her
parents in jail but was reassured that
there was nothing left in that account
um and it turns out when we went through
Court there was a lot more in there than
expected but I still never saw any of
that so she was take making the money
you were making and giving it to her
parents essentially yeah essentially or
putting an account aside it was supposed
to be used for the kids but it never has
been
um okay so what what happened two years
ago
um because you said this all
um the two years of limited contact so
what what was the like what was the
first what happened so
um we were looking at buying a house
together and we live in a plate uh we
live sort of in a very a small town
um when we lived in a small town and
there's a bigger Town sort of a few
miles up the road
um trying to be vague with names and
stuff to make it easier and the sort of
price difference between houses you're
talking a four or five bed house it's
the same price as a two bed house and
the one we were looking at
um we were looking and you know
stretching wages trying to sort
everything out and um I said well we
should move just a few miles down the
road
closer to everything that I needed and
still not far away from her parents and
you know family and whatever and
basically because I wouldn't buy the
house that she wanted it all kicked off
and she said well if that if you're
gonna not do what I want I don't want
you anymore and it sort of went but I'm
gonna be the one with a mortgage I'm
going to be the one with the thing all
of this time what I didn't know was
going on in the background was she was
messaging her friend planning to accuse
me of abuse and I think the plan was for
me to buy a house in in the area get the
mortgage in my name get everything and
then get me kicked out on the basis of
abuse to then be able to keep the house
which is a very common tactic as far as
the way and this all came out
in court
so she was messaging her friend talking
about accusing you of course yeah saying
oh I wish he would hit me hit me um I
wish he would be abusive I wish like she
said that yeah
I'm can I is it in here she submitted it
herself she submitted this yeah so it's
a really dodgy copy I can find it for
you if that's helpful yeah I just was
curious I wanted to see that um so it'll
be in
um of the contents pages on the front
but she submitted um WhatsApp messages
herself
um it would be important statements yeah
witness statements and
um okay so she said to her friend that I
wish that he would hit me yeah where did
this come from her friend said that he
has to hit you no that was that was her
just saying that I wish you would hit me
and then she even said in that if I
accused him of that he would just turn
around and say that I've been hitting
him the whole time so already preempting
the abuse that was going on in the
background now what's quite funny about
that is there are conversations with me
and her where she really hit me in front
of her son and I said like I had to
explain to him and I explained that it
was a mental health related issue and
she had a full-blown go at me made me
apologize so it's actually evidence that
she was aware that she was hitting me as
well we had a conversation about how it
wasn't right that was the first time I
stood up for myself and said that wasn't
okay and I got told that I was in the
wrong for doing that and she then was
telling her friend if I accused him of
anything he would say that I did that
but it was already going on in the
background so she was already getting
her friends
to say like be prepared to that he's
going to come out and say that I'm being
abusive so she was already covering her
tracks and already being like well he's
lying before I've even said anything
which obviously it came completely out
of the blue for me so you you're arguing
about the house and then she says if you
don't get the house I want I don't want
you anymore little you don't know this
at the time but she's messaging your
friends basically plotting yeah to get
to accuse you of abuse yeah so then um
so how did she I know you had issues
um seeing your kids for a while so it
was like the first did she leave so she
she got up and she left the family home
I think Matt's talked to you about this
before where you know make the mistake
of leaving the family home she got up
and actually was the one that left she
took the kids
um and took them to her parents house
and I said they shouldn't be there they
should be with me they should be at home
they should be staying where they've
grown up
um it's the only house they'd known and
they were basically living in a six by
nine room at their parents in bunk beds
uh that like her parents bunk beds her
parents have a six bed house and they
put them in the smallest room together
they can even like give them an extra
room like you know it wasn't the best
situation for them
um and I basically said they should be
staying at home you like all the
parental responsibility staff all the
laws and everything say you can't move a
child without both parents permission or
a court order and she just up to move
them she changed the doctors she changed
the school she didn't change whether
going to change all their address and
everything without any input from me and
basically we turned that I turned up one
day and went look they're not happy here
they want to come back with me can they
come back with me and she threatened to
call the police on me
um we were trying to have a conversation
the whole time my child like my youngest
is screaming that they don't want to go
with their mum and then on one day I had
to drop them off and go to work and as I
was reversing out of her drive quite a
big house quite a big Drive
my three-year-old came running out the
door on her own screaming to get back to
me ran all the way down I picked her up
and gave her a cuddle
and then her her and her parents came
out as I'm picking him up I had to give
her back because I had to go to work
there was no way for me to take her or
do anything and I've already been
threatened at this point with legal
action being the police called on me and
it was it was so hard to add her back
because she was screaming she didn't
want to be there and then two weeks
later when I was getting contact and I
started seeing
um a solicitor to try and get advice and
whatever we had the same thing again
that she was screaming and crying and
you could hear in the recording that her
mum submitted to court her punching and
clawing and screaming to get away from
her mum to get back to me and it was the
most horrific thing that like I've had
to witness and you know you one of the
things is that being threatened to call
the police on and I was just like I'm
just laughing at just how ridiculous it
is because all they should be doing is
coming home with me to be looked after I
was my daughter's Rock for a long time
like I was the only one that could brush
her hair obviously anyone I was picking
up Nursery every day dropping her off I
was doing everything for her and looking
after her and to just have her ripped
away and screaming that she doesn't want
to go with her but then basically being
told by everyone including my own
solicitor if you keep them you will lose
them all together and when that
recording was played in court the only
thing that they said about it was I
didn't do enough to calm my daughter
down
I was in the wrong because I didn't calm
her down to go back
in the other side of the recording that
was submitted you could hear her dad
saying just play the domestic abuse card
her dad said that yeah
do you have the recording list I have
both of them can I see it yeah I can um
obviously it's going to be a difficult
one to keep that one anonymous because
it's oh okay then we don't have to yeah
we don't have to but it is a horrendous
recording outside so so
um it's okay you don't yeah it's fine I
didn't realize it's 20 minutes
um so essentially she went your kids are
screaming that they want to go home with
you yeah the the dad is saying just
called it use these cards so even the
dad's pushing this yeah and in court
they don't really seem to care not at
all they just ignored it they brushed
the office I was still the one at fault
the when you make a statement in court
it says at the bottom I believe this
statement to be true and if it's untrue
um you know there is a chance that you
will go to prison or get a final or
whatever in her statement she said
talking about that incident neither of
the children wanted to go back with me
my son was scared of me and was hiding
under the table from me and that it
wasn't clear that they wanted to come
with me it was never discussed and
basically he had a sigh of relief to be
away from his dad when you can hear in
the recording on the other side my son
just constantly in the background going
I want to go back with Daddy I want to
go back in daddy with daddy now in any
legal term that's perjury which is a
criminal offense when I brought that up
at Court they just went oh it is what it
is and moved on completely now the whole
reason I wasn't seeing my children at
that point when we were going through
and that recording came in was because
of the accusations
and she was lying to get that done and
she just continued to lie and lie in all
of her statements everything that went
through and the courts just went oh well
it is what it is it is what it is it is
what it is as a whole as a result so
there is no punishment for no punishment
for her lying none at all even to the
point of so the accusations because it's
a standard Suite of accusations that get
thrown around now
um if you were in the UK and you decided
to go to probably a solicitor that I
think they'll tell you to go well go for
a coercive controlling Behavior
Financial residual assault domestics
just play off all of them and see what
happens because there is no comeuppance
for it
um Financial control she said I I was
hiding all the finances from her she had
no idea how much money I was earning and
she had very little control over what we
could spend the money on and I wasn't
giving her any every month we had
records that I was giving her about a
thousand pounds a month to you know make
sure that all the bills and everything
we're paying food was done she had a
credit card that was in my name that she
used freely to go out and get coffee
with her friends go on the bus and you
know get around every year I would tell
her if I got a pay increase and it said
sent her the amount down to the down to
the penny how much I was earning even
broke it down before and after the tax
how much it would be bringing home and
yeah basically that you know she at that
time she was filtering money off to her
parents and when I said well that's
surely a lie because she's saying all of
these things on her sworn statement four
lies that have proved with Accu evidence
they went
oh well it doesn't prove that it didn't
happen
and I was like I'm pretty sure that
fundamentally does
sorry I mean I'm like how does that not
yeah how is that not a lie and that that
was one pillar so that's Financial
control so it's like you're saying this
is her lying and they just say well it's
not really lying yeah and they have to
go down the route of oh but why was she
lying and obviously to keep me away from
my children and then they go oh okay
fine move on okay so they accused you of
four types of events yeah Financial
control coercive control corrosive
controlling Behavior
an assault was a was a big one or the
other one actual assault okay I think
coercive controlling Behavior was one
but um yeah domestic Financial abuse
okay so
um what is coercive controlling Behavior
so coercive controlling behavior is
essentially it's where you control every
aspect of someone's life so they're not
allowed to talk to friends family it's
almost kind of what gaslighting falls
under to a certain extent it's basically
a level of where you you control
everything and sort of steer them away
from making their own decisions like
okay them off from their friends and
family deciding where they're going to
live and that sort of oh so that was
sort of like the house I'm guessing she
said that was because you decided we
were deciding but it's your money so but
they would still put that under coercive
control and behavior I mean it
completely brushing over the fact that
I'm from the other side of the country
and we're living right next to her yeah
it's not mine
um but yeah apparently I was coercive
controlling despite the fact that you
know she oh it was things like um I
would constantly call her when she was
out with her sister to find out where
she was or if she went on a night out I
was controlling by asking what time she
was going to come home so me as a man
asking what time my partner is coming
home is apparently coercive controlling
Behavior because I was had no idea where
she was what she was doing
okay and I've got two kids at home and I
just go oh what time are you coming home
and Matt apparently is that's coercive
controlling and then Financial control
that was not saying allegedly she's
saying you I don't know how much money
he's making he he said I couldn't spend
ten thousand dollars on the credit card
yeah some anything like that
assault
um how what did she say that you did so
um she claimed that when we were
together there was an incident so the
first time apparently we slept together
into having sex
um
yeah but then we had a 10-year
relationship after that there was a
couple of other incidents that she
mentioned but they were really sort of
few and far between and there was
um she and her sister concocted a story
that I would try to have sex with her in
my sleep and there was no evidence no
one no messages like you know with 10
years of history between all in all
WhatsApp between all no one could ever
find a message that that was something
yeah and then uh probably the worst and
most
horrific one was he accused
me having her and that's how our second
child came about so she it basically
implied that our second child was a real
baby
wow and I had to sit in court and hear
her talk in such disgusting terms about
me
about something that I fundamentally
think is disgusting
and then to find out that she is
actually saying that a child is a result
of that and you have three kids two two
I have um I have a third of my partner
my current partner so it's her her son
did did that like get around your Social
Circles that she was saying that like
that
um well probably the most horrific thing
um I was arrested at the equivalence
time of a school pickup so I was dragged
out of my house by police officers about
three o'clock in the afternoon so when
all the mums are congregating at school
um and yeah I was taken to a cell to be
questioned about everything that she
accused that she'd accused me of and how
long was she with you after she alleged
that there happened the the initial one
both
um so the initial uh incident apparently
happened before we started dating so
um that was really our first date that
we ended up sleeping together
um so that was her first one and then
there was one
um about apparently
two years into the relationship but then
no incidents Apparently after that
so she was with you for another 10 years
basically and then she said you were
okay I don't
think that really makes sense I think
that doesn't make any sense if you look
at if you're approached by someone you
wouldn't have children with them I mean
I um also have to sort of follow up on
that sort of five seven years there's a
bit of a gap in the middle of messages
from her where she's like I want sex
give me sex I want sex now like as
messages coming through and I'm not
being funny but if I was assaulted by
someone I wouldn't be messaging them
constantly asking for sex yeah I mean
that's that's a given so when you go to
court so did she accuse you because I
understand there's a difference between
like accusing someone of sexual in
family court and in Criminal Court there
is so did she take you to criminal court
at all she uh oh wow she took at the
criminal court she made a statement to
the police which resulted in my arrest
now
for someone to get legal aid in the UK
there is a set of requirements
and if you go on to the legal aid
website and read the list you could just
tick what she did almost she did it like
a checklist
and um he had me arrested
um by making false allegations to the
police
um the police eventually decided that
there wasn't any evidence and a lot of
the evidence I provided contradicted her
story completely
um but my solicitor for Criminal Court
actually turned around and said
I shouldn't have been arrested I should
have been asking for an interview the
arrest was orchestrated by her by her
saying that I was suddenly aware of the
investigation and planning on destroying
evidence and because of that they had to
act quickly to have me arrested
um so they got me so basically I was
arrested as that result otherwise I
would have had I would have just been
asked to come in for an interview and I
wouldn't have spent the night in a cell
and when you get spend the night in the
cell you I got picked up
um I got taken 20 miles from my house
put into a cell no shoes no hoodie no
jumper because you know risks and
whatever
um I was there for about eight nine
hours interviewed probably at 11 o'clock
at night after basically being put in
not having any contact with anyone my
phone had been seized
um being told if I don't give them
access to my phone
um I'd be there even longer I got
fingerprinted dnaed and then we went
through the full interview and they went
okay we've got no more questions for you
you're free to go
they didn't take me home I was left 20
miles away from home with no transport
no way to get home just off you go
and when it's that time at night
there's very little public transport to
get back to where I wanted to so I had
the choice of call my my dad who was
three and a half hours away and they
said if you do that you'll have to wait
in a Cell wait until six o'clock in the
morning to try and get a train home but
I didn't have any money with me
because when they took me they just took
my what I had on me they didn't let me
take anything else or
what actually happened was I had to call
a friend
um which actually was my boss at the
time and she came and collected me from
the police station and was horrified to
find out what had happened I was pulled
out of work during the middle of the day
we're working at home at the time
um and yeah mum's just left I
and at the end of it all
um I had bail conditions put on me
um
which is which was a really weird
scenario because even the police said in
their thing
normally you would get a non-molestation
order
against someone that you're scared of
she didn't want that she wanted an
arrest because the arrest was required
for legal aid a non-molesterion order
would have prevented an arrest and
wouldn't have got her legal aid
um
so
I basically had bail conditions which
said I wasn't allowed to go anywhere
near her which is fine but the police
put in there to prevent any sort of
shenanigans because we know that family
Court's going on we're going to put a
caveat in that you can go up and collect
your children from the house
my criminal solicitor at the time
basically said record everything you're
gonna have to video yourself picking it
up because all she has to do is step out
and say you interacted with me and you
go to prison and don't see your kids all
she had to do was try and have an
interaction with me and when I messaged
her to say look this is really dangerous
for me like I'm really worried about it
could you just ask your parents to bring
the children down to my house
so I don't have to come up there
of the letter between my solicitor and
hers she said no you will continue to
come to the house
to pick up the children this is from a
woman that has said that she's terrified
of me and how I'm going to react but
she's still making me go to the house or
not see my children
when I when I had that I
broke down in my car the first time I
had to go up because I was terrified
like I'm being told that you know if I
have any interaction doesn't mean good
bad any interaction I'm not seeing my
kids anymore I'm potentially going to be
back in a Cell what because I'm having
to go and see my kids and she won't even
get her parents to drop down
if I if that was my daughter and they
said
I want to stay away as much as you want
me away I would be driving them down
every time like if that's what we've
agreement is and that what needs to be
done I would be making sure there are
zero interactions zero chance of any
sort of
anyone getting near them but her and her
family obviously
knew it wasn't so they um so what did
they need to get the free solicitor they
needed an arrest did an arrest
to report me to charity
report me to charity yeah to a charity
so like a domestic abuse charity
domestical charity so like is that one
of the women's shelters yeah basically
okay
um and um to have something from like
child services
or like any sort of welfare check and
basically if you look at her submission
she went down that checklist and just
went yes yes done done what is child
services
um so they are supposed to protect
children from parents so if you've got a
concern about the welfare of a child you
report it to the child services which is
a government agency which kind of go in
and do a welfare check and
okay
okay so what what happens next now can
you can still see the kids are you being
given the whole time the judge has said
that I'm allowed to see them but
they is restricted okay
um so it started off that I was seeing
them one night of fortnight
what does that mean so one night every
two weeks okay so once every so you get
to see them twice a month yeah basically
okay so I would pick them up at nine
o'clock on a Saturday and drop them back
up Sunday afternoon in sort of legal
terms
um staying with a parent
um counts as an overnight
um which is very important for how child
maintenance is measured as well so this
this entire this entire two years while
I'm being kept away from my children
the more the less time I have with them
the more money she gets from me okay so
basically it's in her but it's in her
best interest so that they're paying her
to not let you see the kids I'm paying
her yeah to not let me see the kids I'm
just curious at this point would you
have been fine with like you take
custody and you wouldn't have had to pay
any like you wouldn't have asked her for
child support I wouldn't have asked her
for anything in fact
um my starting point was 50 50. like I
want as much time with my kids as
possible but I understand that she wants
as much time and her before this all
started kicking off and she became
vicious I was still sort of looking
through the whole relationship with
roasting his goggles she was she was had
her parents there to support her they
were working in it they could have
stayed at home with me and I would have
let her have as much time with them
really as she wanted
um but you know I wanted as much time
with them as well they're my kids like
you know I've raised them I was there
for both of their births I was the first
person to hold both of them you know
I've been in their lives the entire time
and yeah I just I was happy to just be
like I'll look after them I'll do
everything I'll do the heavy lift in the
school runs the you know the work you
just enjoy your time with them and I
even said to her the thing even if we
were 50 50 I would still help out
financially to help her you know keep
the same standard with the kids I
wouldn't expect her to buy clothes for
them or anything I would just let them
having like you know if she could afford
she couldn't afford a place she needed
support I would help her like it was
never never off the table but it wasn't
enough for her no
she wanted to hurt me why like where did
this it's just so crazy to me that she
could because you know a lot of times
like the guys that aren't really in the
space or haven't gone through it they'll
say like why
are you dealing with these crazy women
um just pick the right girl you know so
it just it baffles me a bit that it's
like a 10-year relationship and now she
wants like vengeance
because I it was the first time after 10
years where essentially I stood up to or
I didn't like what she was doing I
didn't enjoy so you didn't give her her
way and this was like the temper tantrum
essentially yeah and then I said well I
want my fair share I want fairness I
want
half the time with my children so you go
to you go to court she already had you
arrested and now now you're in Family
Court the criminal court they drop it
they say there's no evidence but because
she got the arrest that's enough for the
solicitor then she goes to family court
and accuses you of four types of views
yeah same as the play at the same as the
police investigator okay so the police
have already invested like this so
Financial control coercive control
sexual abuse and domestic abuse yeah
even though you have all the evidence
and the messages that prove otherwise
yeah but you get to court and they
really just don't care well initially
what happened was I said that in the
first first time and the judge went well
it's a serious allegation we are going
to have to investigate further we are
going to have to push this to a fact
find I think Matt's told you about fat
Vines they are long drawn out processes
so um can you remind me I remember fact
finding is how long uh three days three
and a half days
um okay
so we booked in
for fact find
um we get two days out from the first
one
um because the court system is very
backed up so we're talking there was it
took three months to get a date for the
fact find oh wow it took three months so
she leaves does all this and then oh so
she leaves it takes two months to get
into court before we get told that we're
gonna have a fat find
oh wow okay
um we get told we can have a fat fine
but we can't have a fat fine for three
months
okay so three months
um I pay all my solicitor fees my
Barrister fees and everything the day
before the fat find supposed to happen
she forgot to book a barrister they
won't let her
go in unrepresented so they say we are
going to have to rebook the fact find
for five months later five months later
and the money that I have paid for my
Barrister and solicitor about 10 grand
at this point
is gone there is no way for me to
recover that she didn't turn up to a
hearing and I paid 10 grand for it wow
okay so essentially she leaves gets you
arrested five
and you don't even really get a fair
shot in court for 10 months 10 months so
10 months later you get into the fact
finding and but this point you've wasted
ten thousand dollars or pounds for the
solicitor that you Q can't get this back
and you only wasted the money because
she didn't show up to court and
then you get to court she accused she's
already accused you of four types of
views and they don't really care they
don't seem to care about any of the
evidence no if she's lying They Don't
Really Care no and yeah and you've only
seen we sorry and you've only seen your
kids twice a month for the last 10
months yeah
um the when we got the December when we
got the continuation where the judge
actually said you can have
um two hours on a Wednesday as well so
every Wednesday so I got to see him for
two hours every Wednesday that's a
school pickup to feed them to send them
home which I don't know if you know but
you pick a pick someone up in school
that's half hour gone I've got half hour
to drop them back so I've got an hour
with them and I've got to cook cook and
feed them what time do I really have
with them right I was craving any time
with them it wasn't the best time with
them
um but it did get up and that was the
the only extra okay but okay so it's
even talking four extra hours okay so
even if you say four times a month
that's still nothing compared to used to
see them every day now you see them four
days a month yeah and two of the days
it's really just two hours yeah okay
it's important though that bit of
information where the judge bumped it up
because that judge actually left the
case and well I've got a new judge for
the fact find oh so
okay
um so
now you get to court and what happens in
court we go all the way through the fact
find nothing was found against me that
everything was found that either not
true made up or you know whatever there
was no punishment for
um for that I raised in court that she'd
abused me
um and she brazenly said yes I did hit
him because he was annoying
and the judge went oh okay I moved on
and I was like I'm sorry are we just
brushing over the fact that she just
openly admitted to a crime and that it
was we'll just move on no
they didn't care they didn't care
um we got we got down to the thing and
the judge said
really 50 50 shouldn't be an issue he
should be seeing them more
more weekends he should be seeing them
overnight more times
and she turned around and went no so the
judge went well okay then if you're
going to say no then I'm not going to do
anything so I don't know what the point
of the judge was
but we ran through the all the decisions
found that you know it was nothing
against me and you know this was a whole
waste of time the police believed it was
fictitious everybody nobody had any
concerns about me looking after her
she'd basically dragged me through the
dirt and when I said as well can I at
least get the costs back for
you know for this process it's been
completely unnecessary and we've wasted
eight months at this point they went no
you're burning your own costs
but the time she wasn't even birding her
own costs because she was getting legal
aid from the women's groups no legal aid
is a league is a government thing well
that's a government thing and it's you
have to get that criteria okay
um so it's a it's from the government
but even after it's all been not proved
um she's still got legal aid for the
rest of the process it's the whole
process is you know you get legal aid
because you've been so you know it's
if you've been you should be able to
defend yourself and you know money
shouldn't be a legal barrier for you
being do that but when it's proved that
it's not true you still continue to get
it so actually there's no
disadvantage from throwing that
accusation around because there's no
consequence and even if it's proven
untrue she still gets the legal aid yeah
so what what did he conclude like how
much time did he give you the same the
same they just went okay we'll keep it
going and what we'll do is we'll do a um
a child welfare report so you know this
is another stage that has to go through
so a service called kafkas I've heard of
them before so I know some people have
brought them up okay calf Cass yeah
kafkas okay they come in and basically
do a report and they interview the
children's school every person in the
child's life to see what level they're
at okay they asked to have that done by
October so we're talking another five
months on
wow another five months yeah so it was
another five months before
we got that report okay
That was supposed to be sent out they're
supposed to be coming back as a
as a thing
um her team was supposed to send that
off
was supposed to be sent off to Kafka to
start the review
conveniently they forgot
kafkas didn't get it in time so it had
to be delayed by another month
okay and we're talking now well into the
well into the end of the the second year
wow so this is I've counted 10 11 12.
one year one month one year three months
one year four months so this is almost a
year and a half okay to get better
access to to Children cap cash report
comes out again I raise my concerns that
he has accused me of being an abuser
it's not been founded but there is a lot
of abuse come from the other side I was
reassured by the capcast people that I
think there was nothing to worry about
this time I had moved in with my new
partner it wasn't a decision we made
lightly
um so my
new partner was from a sort of a Summer
Fling 12 years previously me and her
sort of had a really nice relationship
and then sort of went our separate ways
I had worked she had the university and
we sort of found each other and we were
bonding over basically both of our
relationships breaking down
pulling context she's amazing when it
comes to her partner she wants him to
spend as much time like you know if you
ever want to like how a woman should
react to a breakup and you know put in
their child first she's
the ideal model but you know we were we
moved in at that time and
um I started raising my concerns about
you know my ex partner so at the time
and you know saying like you know his
abuse and whatever I get the report back
I was still being labeled doesn't
and all of my concerns were left out of
the report so they don't put any
anything that you had proof of No and
when I said that they went we're not
interested in evidence that's for the
court I'm like how do you make a report
without any evidence okay
um during that time my
my youngest was talking to a therapist
that my partner was kind of pushing how
old were your kids at this time
four and eight four and eight okay so
four-year-old at this time
um goes to a therapist and basically
says oh we we've moved in with
Daddy's new partner and son he touched
me inappropriately so my four-year-old
has now accused my daughter's my new
partner's son I'm actually assaulting
her
to a therapist he's three
and with and she's four they should not
be talking about this the story that was
concocted
um was before I took uh before I had oh
sorry missed an important part in May
um we had a holiday that had been booked
for two years pre-covered and the judge
said you can take them because this was
a pre-arranged holiday so I got to see
them for five days so I got to have this
pre-arranged holiday I had to give that
information to Mum
fine gave that information the holiday
changed slightly originally we were
going to be leaving for my my parents
house
and then we were going to be going on
holiday
um and my daughter said
he
um my new partner son seconded me
touched my private parts when we were at
nanny in Grandad's house the problem
with that story is we never went there
the only person that thought we were
going there was my partner my ex-partner
and suddenly and she also believed that
we were going on holiday with my new
partner and Son but they didn't come
along because we can like book them in
in time so they were left off at home
doing their own thing
and there was all this talk about how
you know this had happened on the
holiday or the build up to the holiday
which is really funny because there's
only one person to believe that story to
be true that was my ex-partner so you
think your ex told that your daughter
daughter to say that yeah
and then I raised that with child
services because that's a real concern
because obviously it's not I then had to
think about how it's going to affect not
only her
because
um because of the whole process that
that goes through but also my partner's
son because obviously he has to go
through the same thing Child Services
didn't do a thorough investigation they
thought it was just a silly story that
my daughter had made up for no reason
and I was told afterwards that if they
hadn't taken that view
my daughter would have potentially gone
through a rocket
and they are invasive
wouldn't wish that on anyone it's a
horrible experience
because you know they basically are oh
it's just an invasive procedure and to
potentially put my four-year-old through
that to try and score some points in
court it's disgusting but no one even
considered looking at her and to
question why when we've gone through
everything that has gone through
previously and the accusations sort of
always come from her and she's even
implied previously that I might actually
assault my daughter it was an
implication in the court for findings
and they didn't bother they just went no
we'll just we'll shut it down it was
just a silly story we'll move on and I
was horrified
because they should be protecting them
so then what happened after the kafkas
report after the Kafka report all of
that was mentioned and we went to we
went to school on November and sort of
the November time so we went in
um again a month later and then what
happened in that court hearing um kafkas
despite all of the accusations and
everything said 50 50 was probably the
best option the only reason they would
be advising against it is because the
current status quo is that they've been
with mum for so long because she kept
the kids away from you yeah okay so what
did they conclude they went the the
judge basically a new judge so we now on
Judge number three
um so there's three judges that have
been on this well four judges we got a
fourth after okay
um said there's no reason that we should
go against kafkash report
and she said oh
um the school and doctors have raised
concerns about him and they went have
you got the letters they've told me and
I've seen the reports is what she told
him and he said
well we're going to have to go to a
final final hearing then we'll do that
three months later okay so now that
you're almost hitting two years almost
because this is that's almost two years
wow yeah
um because the basically the school have
said since they've had a slight increase
in contact with me things have been
going worse and I was like okay well
then we'll see those letters and you
will provide them
and if you don't you're going to be in
trouble and I thought fantastic because
I know they don't exist
I already knew these letters didn't
exist but we still had to wait three
months before we got any sort of
conclusion my time didn't increase
still a bit at the sort of same level
where you know at the moment I thought
for two years to get a day I've got an
evening I'm still seeing them for two
hours in the evening and now my two
hours in the evening is even shorter
because I'm having to drive them further
away because I live further away the
decision I made I even got to the point
where I was considering dropping the
Wednesdays for the well-being of my two
kids because it was horrible for him
right they were spending an hour in the
car for an hour visit rushing their food
down not having a good good time with us
but I stuck with it may try to make it
as fun as possible for them you know we
sung We Danced in the car we were being
silly so we're all round to February
the letters that turn up say the exact
opposite since I've been having more
contact it's been
better
um but since mum has made the accusation
there has been a change but it wasn't
tied into when you it was tied into when
the accusation started and my daughter
stopped attending school properly was
going in late was screaming crying not
wanting to going to the school and that
was exactly what she said was happening
but now it started happening when she
needed a letter to say that that was
happening oh
okay so we have you you can get an
attendance report for her kids at school
and it was fine everything was perfect
she said
there's a problem
and then everything starts going wrong
and then she goes can you write me a
letter to say things are going wrong and
the school went well actually we haven't
seen that there's been a blip but you
know that's not anything related to
because they were smart enough to go but
that's when it started it was fine until
this point that's nothing to do with
so the school have really been on my
side and actually been very pragmatic
about it and really listened to when
I've raised concerns the only ones that
have yeah then we get to court the
letter says no there's nothing to worry
about
um the doctor's letter said that after
an appointment that happened after
um after the accusations are made
William raised the concern that he
wasn't happy but this was after again
they said we haven't heard this before
it was new bit of information and it's
after court and after we you need that
letter and they said this is what he
said but then basically he didn't say
enough to change kafka's mind it should
still be 50 50 but because of the status
quo and I said
but it's an unnecessary delay that was
once again predicated on a lie you've
lied to get at this stage
we get around to February and they
basically go right we are ramping up
the contact and I finally get what what
I want so I get to see them from Friday
to Mondays now
and I get to see them
every Wednesday night and on the
weekends that I don't see them I get to
see them on Thursday night as well so we
now I get six days out of 14. that the
only reason I'm not getting 50 50.
is because
the last two years
they've been with mum and mum has told
lies and lied the judge even said that
is the case
so you spent and how much did you spend
in this time period 47
000 pounds
um and I was paying her the entire time
as well which child maintenance I sort
of say is kind of one of those ones
where I shouldn't have been paying it
but it's difficult to argue that you
shouldn't be paying for the upgrade of
your kids
um 500 pounds a month
okay
and
do you still have to pay child
maintenance uh I do it's dropped
significantly but
the problem with child maintenance is if
I want to get say a second job to try
and increase my income the more I have
more money I need to bring in
to start paying off my debts the more
money she gets from me and at one point
it worked out but if I got minimum wage
job 10 pounds an hour
I would be paying her three pound fifty
an hour I'd be paying
two pounds 50 in tax
and then I would be getting whatever was
left so it worked out that I'd be
getting three pounds she would get 50p
more an hour from me working than I
would be getting wow so it didn't really
make sense to go and find a secondary
second job to try and fix my problem so
in order to get almost 50 50 custody of
your kids
you essentially had to go through two
years of her accusing you of
with no evidence where you had evidence
of her view
you had to get arrested and essentially
they still didn't award you what you
asked for in the beginning which is 50
50 custody so they in a way they
punished you for her doing something
wrong and then she had no punishment why
do you think the courts like why is it
like this because it's like the system
is made up of individual people and
that's what I don't understand like I'd
imagine the judges if they're seeing
case after case after case they don't
see any patterns with these crazy women
fundamentally I think it comes down to
what's easier
and I think it's easier for them to go
oh look it's very easy to prove that six
foot man has attacked a you know an
anorexic lady who weighs basically
nothing
um than it is for them to go well she's
abusive the whole time like because the
question will be like well why didn't
you defend yourself why didn't you do
that the police don't want to look into
any accusations either
um they're again on the same sort of
same sort of idea which is it's really
difficult for us to prove that she's
lied because she would have to admit
that she lied and we don't want to go
down that we don't go down that route so
take too much work for that yeah it's
too much work and it's and they go oh
and even if they got there they'll just
look at her she'll cry and they'll go
well obviously he could have just
defended himself
but that's the the image that's being
put across but I think the biggest
problem is the system incentivizes
pushing down the abuse route because you
get so much out of it if you think about
what she gained from making those
accusations rightly or wrongly
like you know we'll say that it's 100
wrong this did it but what she gained
is such a tactical advantage that if you
want your kids
it's a no-brainer there's no
consequences for doing it but you get
legal aid you get to keep your children
all the time no one's going to question
you about it you get all the support in
the world that you want and you don't
have to do much because everyone will do
it for you because you are now paying
for legal aid and they will cover
everything you take all the stress out
of it and all you have to do is
occasionally turn up for one day and go
oh this has made me really sad and
they'll go okay off you go and oh I
don't want that okay off you go there's
no there's no disadvantage to it
and what's really funny is if I wanted
to try and claim
the legal aid route I earn too much
money so even if I did go down there
every route I wouldn't get it so you can
only go down that route if you oh
because it's one of the things you've
said the benefits yeah you have to be
you have to be below a certain
thresholds oh so that incentivizes it
more because it's like the people with
the most to gain from it get the most
out of it yeah because I mean not to say
but it's like an extra incentive because
they they get child maintenance out of
it too they get and to sort of play a
bit of Devil's Advocate here previously
you didn't have to claim abuse to get
legal aid they changed the rule and if
you look at the statistics it goes from
about
maybe I think 10 15 000 cases to like
hundreds of thousands almost really just
Rockets as soon as they bring in that
you have to have that you can almost see
the point it happens because it just
goes up
and there's no there's nothing stopping
that
Okay so
because I I started doing a lot of
research into this like how bad it is
because I spoke to Matt myself and he
said your story isn't uncommon I was
like I think mine's uncommon because
I've got so much evidence that points
the other way like even to the point
that you know there have been criminal
offensive that have been missed um the
police have failed to do their basic
investigation needs
um they took Give an example they took
my phone
and basically went into it and said if I
don't give it over I'm going to be in
trouble
in their report they said oh your
Diaries may contain information that we
need to prove his innocence
um she went date protection I'm not
giving it to you
data protection doesn't exist in a
criminal investigation otherwise we
could all just go oh don't protection
I've done what you see in CCTV with me
doing that I'm not gonna let you because
that's my face off you go
um but for me it wasn't an issue but for
they've just been arcade we won't push
it
um but that's the sort of level that we
we have to deal with every day but yeah
it's a it's just a ridiculous we're in a
ridiculous situation where every single
service has failed me at some point in
this whole thing Child Services were
called in to get the tick box right near
the end because apparently it was
inappropriate for me to kiss my daughter
good night
my partner reported me to Child Services
because then he knows how long it took
did he just before court Child Services
actually phoned in to the court and said
she's obviously done that to say that
you've got an open child services thing
we know that she's doing that to cause a
scene and try and impact court it's not
an issue we've closed it and the judge
went oh that was good of them to tell us
that okay so now that's closed and moved
on but completely skipped over the fact
that she lied to Child Services no
that's a crazy thing and like a lot of
girls will come on my show and they'll
just say well that guys need to like
fight harder for their kids but you
mentioned um do you mind if I say your
income is that okay yeah you mentioned
you make like 35
000 pounds a year and it's like and you
your parents helped you pay for this
right they sort of how they sold their
retirement investment wow they sold
their retirement investment to help you
pay for this yep that's put a
significant Chunk in yeah
wow all this time as well I'm having to
live
um so what what the the other thing that
child maintenance don't take into
account is if I'm seeing my children one
night a week I still have to play pay
for a place with a bedroom for them I
still have to get all their clothes for
them I still have to look after them
even if it's only one night none of that
is taken into consideration
um I'm then paying her and at one point
I was losing basically I was a hundred
pounds a month short before I bought
food
wow wow
um and I run up child maintenance like
so the child Mason the department of
working pension and said that to them
and said look I'm fighting court and I'm
having to pay court fees and I'm doing
that and
the woman on the other end of the phone
said well if you can't afford to fight
for your kids maybe you shouldn't wow
and I'm like I'm fighting to see them
and she goes yeah but if you can't
afford it then you should just stop and
it's like I can't afford it because not
only is this going on but I don't think
they should be with her but you're
making me pay
essentially but it's like how do they
not see that that's wrong all the people
that work there are they just are they
just like brainwashed by feminism are
they just like it's just baffled I
actually I'm trying to see if I can
interview some people that work there so
I don't even know what they would say so
for my my dad experience as well I was
living with
um I live with my dad so my Mom and
Dad's divorced she did a very similar
thing actually
um made not as bad accusations but
actually at one point got me to sit down
and write a letter to the court
basically who asked me into doing it
right left saying that I don't want to
see my dad and that's from part my mom
made you do that how old were you uh
probably about nine or ten so a nine or
ten she said you have to write this
letter yeah and it was presented to the
court to keep them away when I turned 11
I just upped and left my mum and lived
with my dad and never looked back I
don't actually speak to my mum that
often now I mean I wouldn't either
um did that and you know the more more
things that sort of come out from my mum
like I've realized she was very
course of controlling individual herself
but when my dad when I was living with
my Dad full time I wasn't seeing my mom
at all my brother was spending half the
time with my dad and half time my dad
was still paying job maintenance to my
mum so if you think about it two kids my
dad was having us 75 of the time my mum
was the one that was still receiving the
child maintenance even though he had the
majority so you so you paid 47 000
pounds your dad took money out of his
did your mom help too or was just no
that was my stepmom actually okay so
your dad and your stepmom took money out
of their retirement to help you they had
to sell a house and that's the crazy
thing like girls and I don't think
genuinely women like think about it like
they don't know all this I I just
certainly didn't before I started this
documentary
um and so you're paying a year's salary
to try and get the chance of maybe
seeing your kids and you are sure are
you still at 50 almost 50 50 almost 50
50. the um we're still sort of going
through teething issues but I'm already
being threatened to be dragged back to
court because I'm not willing to back
down on losing time with my kids so wow
so now she's threatening to take you
back to court yeah because
um for example we split bank holidays
and that's written in the court order in
plain English you will split bank
holidays so if I have one she has one
but what she seems to believe is that a
bank holiday consists of me only seeing
them until three o'clock in the
afternoon not a full day and you won't
accept that I won't accept that I say so
no so if I'm if I'm normally supposed to
be dropping the back up nine o'clock on
school nine o'clock on a Monday
well then if it's a bank holiday I'll
drop them at nine o'clock on Tuesday
that's an extra day that bank holiday is
mine I you know it should be 24 hours
the definition legally for child
maintenances and day with is includes
the night so that is the definition of
it
and I was told that that's being
unreasonable and that if we don't come
to a conclusion we're gonna have to go
back to court and I said I'm not willing
to throw any more money at this I've
thrown enough probably worth while
highlighting as well in the last two
um Court hearings I had to go
unrepresented because I ran out of money
so actually if I had paid for the last
two uh last two court hearings it would
have been about another four or five
thousand pounds wow
um so I had to go completely
unrepresented for the last one so it
would have been a lot more but it was
actually Matt that said just go
unrepresented it was not going to make
much of a difference and I kind of found
out that that was true like really it
didn't really make a difference so you
having an attorney doesn't make a
difference yeah I would honestly say no
like I think if anything it just causes
you a load more stress because you'll
find the money it's it's an echo chamber
really they the more that they can get
you to believe that you're gonna win the
more money they get out of you the more
money you're willing to fight it to try
and get some kind of justice for
yourself could you ever press charges
against her for abuse I tried I
genuinely went to the police and made
and the police refused to take my
statement and told me I missed my window
what so they arrested you when she said
that you worked her 10 years ago but
when you went to press charges against
her they refused to take your statement
yeah I tried to get say that not only
she had assaulted me and you know
actually the other way but I've got
evidence that she lied I was told that I
am not the victim in this case the state
is so they believe that you know we were
the ones that were lied to and we don't
care so off you go so I'm not a victim
I'm the one that's been accused of a
crime that didn't happen it's going to
impact my life forever and basically
they went oh you're not the victim move
on
wow
um and yeah I missed my window
apparently yeah because it's like I'm
trying to
I just okay I kind of understand the
money Trail because when I get I I did
it with um Matt when he was talking
about like how all the systems like sort
of live off of men in a way so it's like
the child um support they they make
their money off of men so why would they
help them right yeah it's like the
solicitors their number one client is
the women's groups so it's like why
would they help the guys I'm assuming
right this is just my guess but it seems
like they wouldn't help the the men too
much because then they're going to lose
their clients from the women's groups
I'd imagine and then the women's groups
obviously they're the women's groups so
but I just wonder about all the
individuals in these organizations how
do they not like see what's happening
see I that's the problem I don't don't
say it's as soon as someone makes the
accusation
it's that that's the lie and that's the
standard we're going to go to so I've
spent a long time trying to prove myself
innocent while also saying it came the
other way it wasn't me but they said oh
well that's just you Tit for Tat
basically accusing her because she's
accused me
we're not even going to look at the
evidence because it's a waste of our
time and it's like oh or oh it could be
interpreted the other way like there's
there's an actual message between where
I I was asked by her do you want tonight
and I went I'm really tired and she went
just drink a can of Monster like that's
not acceptable if that message was
flipped
and in fact at one point her Barrister
almost said that like oh you said here
have a can of monsters that actually
that's hers and then she went oh we'll
move on I was like so you were willing
to throw me under the bus saying that
that was okay
coercive you know some of the some of
the phrasing as well that got used in
court as well so the recording oh I mean
if we've got time after this you can
have a quick lesson and just hear how
bad it was
um I was told that I should have done
more was it because that was her
throwing a tantrum that was like if she
wanted ice cream for tea and I said are
you really comparing a child desperate
to get away from their mum to get back
to their dad as the same as wanting ice
cream and they went yeah that's what
we're saying and it was like accepted
like you know I was at low on the totem
pole as ice cream for breakfast
but that's not even the same thing
that's not you know we're not even in
the same ballpark like mums and dads are
equal in the kids lives some parent like
parents can be horrible people
but that's not gender
that's either way but when when we're
getting told the entire time like you
know oh you're not doing enough to fight
for your children you're not doing
enough to talk to you right well because
you're in a position where your dad
could help you but what if you weren't
what are you supposed to do I've spoken
to guys
um sort of friends of mine and sort of
like through acquaintances and whatever
where they've got no one to support them
and they're terrified to go into court
because they're like well what happens
if I lose or you know what is it I can't
fight like I've got nothing to do and
then my story is almost a cautionary
tale as well don't do it because you
there's a good chance you'll get
arrested if you try and push for fair
access to your kids they'll just throw
some kind of accusation and yeah and
well I mean some guys would say in a way
you won now right because you get almost
50 50 which is really sad but like I've
talked to some guys that still don't get
any access to their kids yeah so you you
seem to like be in a better spot than a
lot of people but she could still
tomorrow take you to court and do this
whole thing all over again yeah and I
think the other thing that's probably
important to realize is that the amount
of evidence that I have that shows her
as an abuser as um because he brought me
a whole binder I've never seen anyone
bring this much evidence to me and like
that's part of it you know there's
there's there was another five or six
that went with that and years of like
photos recordings like you know that
went with it and conversations that have
been introduced in concert conversations
between all of the people in our lives
that you can track back because we live
in a digital age and you know I when I
move my phone all my messages come with
me now before your phone died that was
it was gone but now it's all there and
even that wasn't enough
to prove that you know I have an
ex-partner that claimed that she
couldn't even cook for herself look
after herself you know we have that
evidence that and yet she can take care
of the kids she can take care of the
kids and she can't work full-time
because she can't cook for herself or
even get herself dressed but she can
look after the kids full time and that
is the base level for her
and then you've got you know sort of me
as the financially stable parent with a
partner that is very well qualified for
the children obviously this bit can't be
included but she's a special needs
teacher oh wow so when you talk about
who is the most responsible for the kids
you know you've got a stable dad stable
job no issues a partner that is a
special needs teacher that's bought in a
big house everyone has their own bedroom
you know able to go and she can't even
dress or look after herself and I'm
still getting less time than she is well
I'm even impressed that on 35
000 pounds a year that you could afford
to get a house like that means you're
really good with money we're renting at
the moment yeah so but well you said you
were looking to buy a house yeah I mean
that's that's impressive honestly like
the cost of living in England is high so
it means you're good with money yeah um
so average house price around our area
is about 400 000. yeah so it's it's a
that's that's so it's crazy so it didn't
even matter what evidence he brought
like nobody cared nobody cared and
that's that's probably the biggest
highlight of it of it all is that you
know actually if you took the gender out
and put us both on paper one would come
out significantly higher than the other
and what's happened in this case is
we've gone mum is more important ignore
all of that and let's just push down did
you ever think about like giving up
during this at all
do you mean giving up the fight or
giving up all together giving up all
together well but I guess both
um was on my mind yeah like
genuinely like it got dark
the only thing that got me through were
those two
night that was it that's what was
holding on to every time I got knocked
back
like it hurt like
but it's like I can't leave them in the
situation they're in like you know
I
I held on
and it was it was hard I did either
yeah I thought that so I can't even
imagine the frustration like you think
you're you're finally going to court you
have your day in court and then every
time you go to court they just they just
don't care about any of the evidence and
they just extend it so it's like every
three months you're thinking you're
about to get Fair access to your kids
and then they just keep
they don't even want to listen and
that's the that's the most
horrifying thing and the thing is that I
was witnessing my children being hurt
this whole time and concerns legitimate
concerns about their well-being my
youngest was being told that she was
sick all the time and at one point she
was put on antibiotics for something
really minor and I was being told she
could barely get out of bed she could
barely move the doctors had seen this
and then I picked her up and I took her
to like a soft play area she was
bouncing around jumping laughing in
there for two and a half hours running
around not a single thing wrong with her
but she's been off school like you know
being I was being told that she was
paralytic but I know from my experience
that if you put enough paracetamine huh
she just Falls over
because you know so they were addressing
her basically so she could accuse so
they so your ex could say that the sun
used her no so she was basically just
shooting them to be like keep them ill
because she wanted them all the time she
has a real issue with um
it used to be called monks houses by
proxy but it's now I think like made up
illness or something that's got a
different name but basically it's where
you project sickness onto a child
okay
um and she was doing that with my
daughter and she has done that a few
times to keep my daughter out of certain
situations or try to stop me having fun
and so she was joining your daughter
essentially yeah I don't want to say
that that's what she was doing because
you know sometimes like we're venturing
very much into liable but
my ex she used to believe that she was
sick all the time but
um our children were sick all the time
if you gave my daughter paracetamol she
would be really lethargic so calpol is
the common one and then she went to the
doctor saying that and was given
antibiotics and then when I saw her the
next day she was completely fine and had
none of these symptoms
so if you put that evidence together
it's concerning but to make an
accusation is very difficult because
obviously
were you ever afraid that she would
abuse the kids like she abused you
um
mentally yeah I think I don't know
physically I do have concerns about my
son because my son looks a lot like me
and there's a lot of
things that have been said that you know
do make me worry that she's projecting a
lot of anger towards me onto him
um you know he looks like a very little
version of me
and that does consent me to a certain
extent and I do have concerns about our
ability to look after them I don't know
how far it will go and at the moment
they're being complacent
and when I was complacent things were
okay it's when I started not being so
complacent that things went wrong and
that's the same with me and me when I
was in relationship with her and me when
I was in a relationship with my mum as
well while I was complacent I followed
her rules
everything was fine as soon as that
didn't happen
you started flying okay so it's like a
control thing yeah so as long as because
would you say that she was a narcissist
your ex yeah 100
okay everything was about her and her
needs and
um there's there's like entries as well
where
um he would complain about her parents
and her sister not giving her the
intention she needed because she was
poorly and the only person that was
giving her attention at the time was me
but they were so self-centered like she
was saying oh I'm so poorly and no one's
even bothered to ask if I'm okay and
that's the sort of level that she was at
and if you didn't sort of pants to her
you would get an earful or Guild trips
into like so essentially if she if she
if you didn't follow her rules then
then that's when the abusive Behavior
started yeah and it was similar do you
think that
um you're like the because your mom was
the example you had do you think that
had anything to do with picking her do
you think it was just bad luck probably
I mean it was probably a part of me that
you know weirdly found some sort of
comfort in it because that was the most
common like I don't I don't think it's
uncommon and you know it probably
probably is and I think a lot of the
time as well I was trying to do what was
best for for the kids the kids and you
know you you make it work like you know
okay so I was getting
okay justifying it in my own head is
okay I was getting hit a few times but
you know at the end of the day I'm still
getting to look after my kids and you
know there's whatever and it's like oh
and it's you know she's she's just
having a bad day she's she's struggling
it's not anything to do with me she's
not actually angry at me she's just
upset with the world she's upset that
things haven't gone her way or you know
I would say just make make an excuse for
her every time it's like oh maybe I did
wind you up a little bit or you know oh
maybe I did deserve that
but
you know there's no there's no excuse
for like hitting someone though no but
again what what would be my recourse for
it there's nothing you can do no because
you go to the police they laugh at you
and
if you hit her back then you're in
trouble yeah how long do you think you
would have stuck it out for at least
till your kids were out of the house
um
if she didn't leave possibly the last
argument was basically me saying I'm not
putting up with your [__] anymore
um and I went no like that's it like she
would she would often use that as a
tactic which was like I'm going to take
my stuff and I'm going to go to my
parents and then she'll come back like a
few hours later saying oh you've really
upset me and expect me to apologize the
difference with how we actually broke up
was I just refused to apologize because
I said I've done nothing wrong in this
scenario I've just raised my concerns
that I'm putting everything into this
and not getting much in return and she
spent probably a good month kept coming
back to the house while it was just me
and her coming in to get stuff talking
to me she refused to give me the key
back to their house as well so she could
keep coming in and like you could let
yourself in if you wanted to and just
come down and chat to me or like you
know pick up a few bits here and there
we would have a lot of contact when it
first happened but I think that was her
trying to gauge whether I was going to
let her back in and as soon as we said I
said to her no that's it I'm done
we said that on the Friday at
four or five o'clock
on the Monday morning
when child maintenance was open to make
a phone call that's when she claimed
child maintenance
so if you're talking about in the
available times you had to collect it to
make the original request it took less
than an hour to phone up and be like I
want money
there's no
no like oh we're going to build it up
slowly or you know let's see how this
goes see where we land see right now I
want all the money and she was saying
that they were with her full time so she
could get maximum amount of money how
long do you think she'd been planning
this I know that was from at least
November that was the first time but she
was visiting her friend sort of in the
evenings a little bit more regularly so
yeah she would regularly go over to her
friend's house and they would drink and
get high and then come back and she
would be out of bed for the whole rest
of the day so that she'd been pla I
think she'd been playing it for a while
but you know the first point I can say
is she was 100 doing it from
six months beforehand okay so at least
six months she'd been planning it what
baffles me is there's no consequence for
anything and if anything there's just a
reward and even like calf cast making a
report labeling you an appear even after
you proved that she was the one that was
amending you and they just don't care
yeah the report said that she's made
excitation abuse and that is still a
concern for her and that was very much
put in the report as a as a fact and it
was like but you've missed the fact that
I spent thousands defending myself and
you also missed the fact that I
mentioned that she had been doing the
same and it still hasn't been addressed
but it was addressed initially in my
original court papers that I said these
are my concerns about her but they were
never addressed in the entire time of
court because she made the bigger like
bigger accusation so she threw the big
light out and that's what it all focused
on is there any way for guys to avoid
this like it doesn't seem I've been
trying to think of ways when you have a
child even if you avoid marriage it
doesn't seem like there's really any
good ways to avoid this situation
happening there isn't and it's that's
the real difficulty is there is no way
to avoid this you just have to hope
that you get a good one that's willing
to put the kids first that's willing to
put all the bitterness and the spite
behind them
and accept that
you as a couple didn't work
but at the end of the day it's not who
cares if you don't work as a couple
there are two for me there's two
beautiful kids in this world because of
us and we should be doing anything to
make their lives as easy as possible
we should be doing anything to look
after them and if if my son turned
around to me you know and said I don't
want to spend much time with you or you
know I said this at the beginning if he
was with me the whole time he went I
want to go see Mummy
as long as it's not because I've told
him off for misbehaving you know like oh
I've gone in and I've you know stabs the
tires of the car you're in trouble I
want to go with mummy no but if he went
oh I just want to go see Mummy I put him
in the car and I drive him over and see
it give her a call and say he wants to
see you are you all right are you free
can we make that work
because that's what he needs he needs
that stability but doesn't matter how
reasonable I am in court and how much
like you know I put that across or
whatever I have to prove that I have a
right to see my kids
and it's just
there but she's never had to prove
anything